Les héros de la Terre aiment les feuilles
la femme sage et le vent étoilé
feuillage de
foule
[Musique]
Rumeur
jusqu'à l'automne
semer à nouveau le pain sur la terre
manteau
sors de
marteau et
extrait
Des larmes de
mettre à la terre le
s'est levé pour son
branches
distribué dans son
architecture
étaient les fleurs
invisibles parfois ils fleurissent
en terrasses C'est l'arbre du Libre
l'arbre la terre l'arbre le nuage l'arbre
pain l'arbre flèche l'arbre poing le
l'arbre à feu n'emporte pas les eaux tumultueuses
de notre nuit C'est le
arbre de
Libre C'est l'arbre du libre
à l'arbre p L'arbre l'
ab le
eau la nuit C'est l'arbre
Les
[Musique]
gratuit
regarde son
cheveux bouche ses rayons
renouvelé, prends ton pain et ton
pomme toi
le cœur et toi
cheval et montures Garde dans le
frontière dans le
limite de votre
ojas C'est l'arbre du Libérez le
arbre terre l'arbre nuage l'arbre pain
l'arbre la flèche le poing de l'arbre l'arbre
le feu ne noie pas les eaux tumultueuses de
notre nuit, c'est l'arbre
des
Gratuit C'est l'arbre des pertes
terre le volume suis pain suis suis le
Aimer le
arroser selon la saison C'est l'arbre du
Gratuit C'est l'arbre de l'arbre du
les gens de tous les peuples du
la liberté du
combattre l'arbre c'est l'arbre c'est l'arbre
de la liberté de
[Musique]
lutte
Oh